[Music]
long before highways and even before the
railroads canals helped the American
economy grow that time has long passed
but there's a new glimpse into what life
was like on these waterways after a
massive restoration Washington DC's CNO
Canal is once again welcoming boatloads
of visitors for a lesson on this
important chapter of American history
as this vessel takes visitors on a
time-honored Expedition squeezing under
low bridges and through narrow walls
it's 30 000 pounds are guided entirely
by hand this boat is a flat bottom has
no keel so it's it just Maneuvers like a
living room couch Franklin Santa Croce
captains today's trip on the Chesapeake
and Ohio Canal in Washington D.C so is
it okay that we're bumping into things
yes it's a canal boat it's designed to
bump into things Santa Croce moves the
boat much the same way his predecessors
did two centuries ago when this passage
revolutionized trade
the canal locks boats between heavy
Gates before deckhands change the water
level
floating the boat from one lock to the
next and allowing barges to move through
elevations
as it passes the historic Georgetown
neighborhood the boat retraces a chapter
of American History defined by both the
promise of Westward Expansion and gritty
perseverance
this Waterway helped modernize life for
Generations in the Mid-Atlantic by
providing a path for essential Goods
like coal
this spring a tour recreating the first
mile returned after 11 years as part of
a massive restoration are you nervous
when you took this first ride out oh
absolutely terrifying it's a lot of boat
I mean it's 80 feet long and 13 feet
wide and that pass we're going to be
going through is probably about 16 feet
wide powered by electric motors rather
than the mules that traditionally guided
a boat it tops out at a Brisk two miles
per hour but history takes its time five
houses down
is where George Washington negotiated
the purchase
of the land for the city of the District
of Columbia George Washington
1791. this was a stable back during the
Heyday of the canal Rex Carnegie heads
education Outreach for the Georgetown
Heritage Foundation which helped fund
the boat's return Why was it so
important to bring a canal boat back to
the CNO Canal here it's a good way to
connect folks to the history whether
that's recent history here in Georgetown
or whether that's the 200 year history
of the canal this is crazy the tours
have been deemed an instant hit nowadays
everything's so mechanical everything's
automated so seeing people actually get
out and use that muscle power that is
the connection to our ancestors here the
lock system in and of itself is
fascinating that's one of the reasons
why we always gather a crowd I mean
people are always excited to see this
boat either go up or come down that lot
a vision from George Washington himself
long before highways the Founding Father
imagined waterways linking the east
coast to the great lakes in Ohio River
the CNO Canal covers nearly 185 miles of
that mile zero marks the start planted
in front of a complex with its own
storied stamp on American history the
Watergate the canal then weaves along
dramatic waterfalls and through Mountain
tunnels on its way to Cumberland
Maryland its destination nestled in the
Allegheny Mountains the path opened for
trade in 1850 running alongside the
Potomac River let's go where we jumped
on the water with Christiana Hansen from
the CNO Canal National Historical Park
what did this area look like 200 years
ago so the Sano Canal it was a highway
you would have had bumper-to-bumper
boats the same way you would have had
bumper to bumper cars today going into
DC it was a very busy Place Hanson took
us to park headquarters in Williamsport
Maryland the Canal's halfway point this
is one of the original buildings along
the CNO Canal it is yes it's about 200
years old Canal boats would come up in
the Basin here and unload coal we would
then load the coal into the trains and
they would head off to go and power the
area
when Canal construction started the
project was an ambitious one and one of
the country's first large-scale civil
engineering projects
despite the promise of its name the
Chesapeake in Ohio Canal never made it
to the Ohio River Valley instead ending
in Cumberland Maryland after running out
of funds operators still found plenty of
coal there and it became an early supply
chain Heyday of the canal is the 1870s
this is right after we've had a civil
war so our country is rebuilding in
really new and different ways the canal
is really busy trade is expanding
the peak of its Heyday lasted about a
decade during the 1870s but the canal
operated for nearly a hundred years
communities grew on and along the water
as laborers including families work the
canal through all hours and Seasons some
of my favorite pictures are kids with
ropes around them that you go why is
that kid leashed oh it's so they don't
fall in what a childhood right but you
also wouldn't lead mules so the the big
engines on the canal boat were mules and
kids helped lead the them while Canal
trade thrived the railroad remained a
fierce source of competition eventually
overtaking it and after several
catastrophic floods the canal closed in
1924. is this in some ways a failure I
think it's a grand experiment so the the
canal it's a struggle to keep it running
and it was even back in the day you're
working against nature and that's what
they were struggling with in the 1800s
as well trains were getting better and
better faster and faster today it's one
of the most visited national parks
surpassing even Yellowstone as people
continue to honor a tradition of
exploring and dreaming of more this
canal the railroad the planes that are
flying overhead all of these things
connect us to that tradition and the
thing that we can hope for is that
things will become easier and more
efficient which is also ironic
considering how much we want to preserve
these chapter of American History so we
can learn from that absolutely that is a
story of the people not just the dates
and not just the famous folks but real
Everyday People how does that connect to
where we are and where we're going
and it really was revolutionary at the
time because either you don't really
have many options at that point in
History either you put it on on a cart
or a horse and it you can't really go
very fast or very far or you put on a
river and navigating those wild rivers
can be difficult so this really helped
open up a new way of life for so many
people more people visit than
Yellowstone that's amazing including me
that was one of my favorite places to go
when I lived in Washington I always
wanted to ride one of those you beat me
to it girl and mile mile zero the
Watergate yes
that was very cool very cool story stamp